[JONATHAN WOSEN]: So the idea behind any vaccine is to introduce
some piece of a virus to your body so you can mount an immune response
And then your immune system sees those fragments
and learns to respond to it.
[ALBERT BOURLA]: You do things in parallel.
Research, trials, manufacturing, and distribution.
[MIKE MCDERMOTT]: So if we think about how long
we would take to build our manufacturing network,
typically that would be a two to three year process.
We shrank it down to about five months.
[NATHAN VARDI]: There are some important reasons why messenger RNA
was appealing for developing a COVID-19 vaccine.
First of all, the virus itself is an RNA virus.
So it lent itself to this technology.
[PHIL DORMITZER]: In an RNA based vaccine, you simply inject the
instruction set that teaches your body how to make a piece of the virus.
[LAURIE GARRETT]: This is going to have a huge impact down the road.
[FRANK SNOWDEN]: It's wonderful….
What's happening is an extraordinary scientific breakthrough.